لحظات خلال رحلة تجارية بعد
فتح أحد الأبواب بينما كانت الطائرة على ارتفاع
مئات الأمتار عن الأرض ونسمع
الآن أنه تم القبض على أحد الركاب
أيضًا، فلنتحدث إلى باولا
هانكوك التي تعيش معنا في سيول، أعني أن
الفيديو يقول ذلك  الجميع
يتساءلون كيف حدث ذلك بشكل
جيد، هذا صحيح، ماكس
وخبراء الطيران يتساءلون كيف يمكن أن
يحدث الآن. ما نعرفه في هذه المرحلة
من آسيانا هو أنها كانت رحلة جوية من
جزيرة جيجو الكورية الجنوبية إلى دايجو،
كان ينبغي أن تكون  لقد استغرقت هذه الرحلة ما يزيد قليلاً عن 40 دقيقة،
وقد هبطت الآن بسلام في الساعة
12:45 ظهرًا ولكن قبل حوالي دقيقتين إلى ثلاث دقائق من
الهبوط، فُتح باب الطوارئ
الآن، وهناك حوالي 700 قدم على ارتفاع ما يزيد قليلاً عن
200 متر فوق سطح الأرض في هذه المرحلة كما
تقول شرطة دايجو تقول ذلك  لقد
ألقوا القبض على رجل في الثلاثينيات من عمره، ويقولون إنه
فتح الباب بالفعل،
ووفقًا للشرطة، يقولون إنه
اعترف بفتحه لكنه لم
يخبرهم عن سبب قيامه بذلك. يمكنك الآن
رؤية الرؤية هناك لكيفية قيام
تؤثر هبوب الرياح على
الركاب داخل الطائرة، لكنني
تحدثت إلى أحد خبراء الطيران الذي
شعر بالذهول لأنه كان في حيرة من أمره بشأن كيفية
حدوث ذلك من الناحية الفنية،
ويبدو أنه من غير المعقول أن
يتم فتح الباب في المقام الأول و  ثم
ضد Airstream
أم مستحيل من الناحية الفنية ولكن بطريقة ما
حدث ذلك أه ربما
بعض العطل
لذلك كان هناك تحقيق واضح
بشأن الدخول في هذا مع آسيانا أيضًا مع
إيرباص ونحن نعلم أنه في هذه المرحلة 12
شخصًا 12 من هؤلاء الـ 200 الذين كانوا على متن الطائرة فعلوا ذلك
يعاني تسعة منهم من فرط التنفس، وقد
ذهب تسعة منهم إلى المستشفى ولكن
قيل لهم أن جميع هؤلاء التسعة كانوا
إصابات طفيفة، لذا يقول الخبراء إن حقيقة
أنها كانت قريبة جدًا من الأرض وعلى وشك
الهبوط تعني أن الجميع على الأقل
كانوا يضعون أحزمة الأمان الخاصة بهم، لذلك هناك  لم تكن هناك
أي إصابات خطيرة ولكن من الواضح أنه كان
حادثًا مرعبًا لمن كانوا على متن الطائرة
ويظل السؤال قائمًا كيف
يمكن من الناحية الفنية أن يتم فتح هذا الباب
بينما لا يزال في الهواء
مقابل تيار الهواء